I do love grape should have listened to
my MJ my grandmother that's Khloe
Kardashian addressing her split with
Tristan Thompson I do want to ask about
this character that you had a baby with
oh man yeah oh yeah is it time to stop
dating basketball players
[Applause]
Kim Kourtney and khloé were guests on
Mondays Las Vegas episode of Jimmy
Kimmel Live when KOCO got candid about
her love life I don't you know I like
what I like what can I say yeah do you
like basketball I actually do you do do
you like love it what do you ever play I
don't play basketball I just like to
answer you like the whole thing yeah not
just the height thing that this thing no
it's the whole thing of it all but I do
a grave should have listened to my MJ my
grandmother I should probably start to
date like accountant motherhood just
puts life into perspective and what's
important to you after announcing she's
expecting a new addition to the family
via surrogate for the second time Kim
revealed to Jimmy her in Kanye's new
bundle of joy and they have a family
name actually I do have one name I was
truthfully thinking about just naming
him Rob my brother Rob yeah then it's
kind of like North Saint Chicago Rob I
really go but I really was feeling that
or like you know Robert and my brother
approved it yeah and so that's like our
one kind of name I'm really freaking out
and Cortney admitted her son rain would
have had another name her ex Scott
Disick got his way I would try out a
different name on a different days
the whole day one day rain his name was
Preston for one full day and how do you
know if it's working or not I was like I
know in my soul his name is rainin Scott
didn't believe me
and I was like no I know his name is
rain and he's like his name is Preston
so I was like fine let's call him
Preston for a day in it it didn't work
out no [ __ ] Court also dished on what we
can all expect to see at her 40th
birthday bash later this month and there
are a lot of rules
I'm Emma Stone Ivana what are the rules
of your birthday parties Courtney what
are they oh my god no speeches no
speeches uh-huh mom is not allowed to
cry if my mom cries I have to somehow
shuttle doubt if she cries shuttle my
mom out it's never a dull moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]